three to five common mistakes you see
new actors making onset common mistakes
number one no actors for the most part
and some actor is which just through
egos were always shape believed that
acting is about talking or speaking
their lines they have no understanding
of the art of listening we are having a
conversation what a conversation is you
speak I listen closely to what you're
saying because I want to respond to your
question most actors have memorized
their line so no matter how you say it
or what's anything they just respond
with their line on camera it looks like
no wait a minute she was crying Oh Becky
you want to go to the prom no no she was
crying when you give it a flower oh yeah
take two hey Becky you want to go to the
prom cut you don't have a long talk in
the corner okay second biggest mistake I
think is that
some actors are not collaborators you
know it's like they're so unsecured it's
like they're seen and some they go in
with attitude like well this is my Sikhs
have more lines than you you know so you
know and there's two people on the scene
it's two people on the scene you don't
know monologue it's just you but there
are people's egos were so large that
you're not even there so it's like
that's how good they can be and that's
annoying as hell the third thing is
nerves
I mean I've literally seen I had to stop
shooting a scene because in the middle
of this scene the actor was sweating so
badly that we at the cut are you okay
what happened when I say sweat I'm
talking about because internally they
are so worried about the fact that
they're not doing it right that they
just something internally happens and
they just are terrified and so as a
director you get a call and give them
you know make sure they know that
they're protected make sure it's if they
you you gotta give me assurance because
acting is responding it's it's it's it's
surrendering it's not holding on to
safety that's easy for me to say but try
it sometimes try going in and trying to
do it and you don't know how it's gonna
turn out you must how was i how how did
it go was great
see it you know it's like you don't know
how it was because you were involved in
it and not knowing what to do is we're
not feeling safe that you've done it
well it's it's it's a challenge that one
well they say having a big ego and a
small you go is pretty much the same
thing it's just sort of different ways
of dealing with it having a big ego I
think is a sign of a small self regard
having a small ego is similar I think I
forgot his name but a Wayne Dyer a
lovely entire and he said you know the
key to having a great life is to get rid
of your ego and the audience said what
are you talking about he said do you
know what that the word ego stands for
e.g oh he goes to the born he says 'i
edging g-god zero out
said your ego ages God out and without
that force in your life he says you have
nothing but empty accomplishments and he
says try eating those empty
accomplishments when you're sitting home
alone because nobody likes you in your
mansion
said it's more comfortable on being on
the street he said but when you ride by
that person sitting on the street it
looks familiar
I think he's brilliant and true I know
very wealthy people who are miserable
give him any money didn't throw the
whole cars in fill a hole closing to
fill a hole the casein didn't fill the
hole emissions it then from the hole
there's something else you'd have to
have you must think I know everything
but I do know because I've had a lot of
it that all those things don't some hole
if you don't have self love
even if somebody else loves you if you
don't have self-love tell my daughter
every day I say you know never forget
men treat you the way they see you teach
yourself
don't treat yourself the way you think
he should perceive you treat to sell
yourself the way you want to be treated
I think it's a general for people I love
quotes so I can give you 3 my favorite
quotes sounds great
you